>> Jane Sanchez: Hello,
everyone, good evening.
My name is Jane Sanchez and
I have the honor of serving
as the 25th Law Librarian
of Congress.
Welcome to The Library
We are very pleased -- I'm
sorry, you can't hear me?
Okay. We're very pleased to
host you today in celebration
of The Heritage of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights,
a milestone document
which underpins all
international human rights law
and inspires us to
continue to work to ensure
that all people can gain
freedom, equality and dignity
and this year it turns 70.
Human Rights Day is
observed each year
to commemorate the adoption
of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights.
The Declaration is defined as a
common standard of achievement
for all peoples and all nations
and it is considered the
first universal statement
that all human beings have
certain inherent rights
that are inalienable.
It was drafted by
representatives
with different legal and
cultural backgrounds,
from all the regions of the
world, and was proclaimed
by the United Nations
General Assembly in Paris
on December 10th, 1948.
Our own Eleanor Roosevelt,
former UNA-USA Board Chairwoman
and trailblazer, chaired
the UDHR Drafting Committee
and was integral
to its adoption.
The Declaration, itself, is
the most translated document
in the world, available in
more than 500 languages.
We, at the Library of
Congress, have decided
to celebrate this
remarkable anniversary
by hosting an even this
evening that will engage
and educate all of us.
Our topic tonight is
The NAGPRA, I don't know
if that's pronounced a different
way, NAGPRA -- okay, thank you.
The Native-American Graves
Protection and Repatriation Act.
This Act mandates the return
of specific kinds of objects
to Native-Americans, makes
illegal their trafficking
across state lines and is
specific about the process
and the procedures for
archaeological excavations.
Tonight we are going to
hear more and learn more
about NAGPRA thanks to
our three Panelists.
And now please allow
me to introduce
and welcome Sarah Glass, who is
the Notice and Grant Coordinator
at the National NAGPRA Program
at The National Park Service,
Shannon Keller O'Loughlin,
the Executive Director
of the Association on American
Indian Affairs, and Emily Palus,
the Deputy Division Chief
of Cultural Paleontological
Resources
and Tribal Consultation at
The Bureau of Land Management.
Thank you for joining
us this evening.
Shall we start?
Sarah, would you please give
us a bit more information
and general overview
of the Native-American
Graves Protection
and Repatriation
Act, what is NAGPRA?
>> Sarah Glass: Great question.
Thanks, Jane, and thank you
very much for having me.
I'm so honored to be here
tonight with my fellow Panelists
and excited to talk a
bit about what it is I do
on a day-to-day basis,
so thanks.
I hope everyone doesn't
mind, but I am going
to keep some notes, keep
checking on my notes here
because as we were planning
this we were all joking
about how each of us
individually could talk
about these things all
day for hours and hours,
so just as a way of
keeping myself on track
and making sure we have plenty
of time for questions I'm going
to consult some written
stuff here.
It looks like I'm
not the only one.
So I wanted to start with
a quick story actually
to help me put NAGPRA in a
bit of historical context,
and I'm going to describe
a scenario that I've taken
from real life but I'm going
to kind of paraphrase it
and not include quite as many
factual details as I would.
But imagine that it's the
United States in the 1970s
and they're building a highway
across a state in the Midwest,
so they're digging, laying
down the road, and they come
across a group of burials
that they had no idea.
You know, they're digging
up land and, surprise,
there were people on this
land before we showed up
and started building roads.
And those burials that
they uncover they can tell
from contextual clues,
from items buried
with the individuals that 11
of these say 12 were those
of white settlers, Anglo
burials, while the 12th one
with some grave goods and
objects they could tell
that it was clearly the remains
of a Native-American woman.
So what do they do when
they uncover these graves?
They call in state
archaeologists,
they call in the right people
who are supposed to respond
to these types of
situations, and they proceed
to very respectfully and very
carefully exhume those 11 white
settlers' graves and
immediately rebury them
in a nearby local cemetery.
Now the 12th grave, the
Native-American woman,
they put her bones in a box
and they shipped that box
to a University to be studied
because Native-American peoples
were not considered anything
more than specimens to
be collected and studied
until this Act, NAGPRA,
as passed in 1990.
So I think it's important
to keep in mind
that these are human
beings, that these,
NAGPRA has a very purposeful way
of addressing some very big
wrongs and historic, you know,
it's a healing process for a lot
of people with dealing with it.
So I just tell that
story to kind
of contextualize what we're
all talking about today.
So and this is not
a new problem,
ever since first contacts,
Native-American peoples
have been fighting
to protect their rights
while being treated
like scientific specimens,
objects for study,
instead of human beings.
Archaeologists, anthropologists,
random people who felt
like going out and just digging
up amassed huge massive
collections that were then put
into museums or onto shelves
controlled by Federal agencies.
And, unfortunately,
in some parts
of the world this is still
perpetuated today, this mindset
of collecting, storing,
I mean you can go
to the Natural History
Museum and that's
where Native-American
topics are often covered.
It's certainly changing today,
but I mean Archaeology 101 today
they tell you Indiana Jones was
a really, really
terrible archaeologist,
but that's the image that
everyone has in their mind of,
oh, yes, this is
such a great field.
So NAGPRA is inextricably linked
to kind of the racial history
within the United States and it
took a lot of fighting and a lot
of time, the Civil
Rights Movement,
the American Indian
Movement through the 60s
and 70s were really a turning
point, a pivotal moment
to organize and make their
voices heard in a way
that they could get some
change enacted in Congress.
So that led to the
passage of the NMAI Act,
the National Museum of the
American Indian Act in 1989,
as well as the NAGPRA
right afterwards
in 1990, November 16th, 1990.
And so I like to call it a
very small but mighty law
because it's pretty short,
it doesn't take you very long
to read the whole thing, but it
covers multiple areas of US law.
So it's administrative
law, it's human rights law,
it's Indian law, and it's
property law, so there's a lot
of different pieces and elements
that are all kind of entwined
and overlapping and
makes people think
that it's very complicated
sometimes.
But what it also is at its core
is a process, so it's a process
for determining the rights
of lineal descendants,
Indian tribes and
Native-Hawaiian organizations
in the human remains and
certain cultural items,
including funerary objects,
sacred objects and objects
of cultural patrimony.
It applies to Federal
or tribal land,
as well as to Federal agency
and museum collections,
so there's a land element,
a collections element.
And the term museum,
when I say museum,
we actually under NAGPRA it's
defined a bit more broadly
than what most people think of.
Museums under NAGPRA could
be, it's any institution
that has Native-American
artifacts or items
and has received
Federal funding.
So a museum under NAGPRA
could be a museum as we think
of it today, but it could
also be a historical society,
an anthropology department
of a University,
a county coroner's office,
a police department,
or even a library that has
items, historic objects.
So it's not just museum in the
sense that most of us think of
and it, I should
add, does not apply
to the Smithsonian Institution.
Here we are in DC,
lovely Smithsonian,
because the NMAI Act
that I mentioned earlier
that was passed actually
covers repatriation
for that institution,
so that's one
of the things that's not
covered under NAGPRA,
as well as foreign institutions.
NAGPRA is US law, it's
domestic law, it does not apply
to the international field.
So essentially what NAGPRA does
is it established timelines
for museums and Federal agencies
to inventory their collections,
consult with Native-American
tribes
and Native-Hawaiian
organizations,
and then to notify everyone
of their determinations
regarding cultural affiliation
and repatriation through and
via the Federal Register.
So this administrative
process is just one
of the major provisions
under NAGPRA,
there's actually four
others that we handle.
First, it established the
NAGPRA Review Committee,
which is a Federal Advisory
Committee that hears disputes
and serves as a resolution
and advisory body.
They don't have any legal,
their determinations have no
legal bearing, but they are kind
of the highest level that one
can take before going to court,
one's issues to be
heard about NAGPRA.
They also are, the
other provision,
another is that we
authorize grants to museums
and Indian tribes,
Native-Hawaiian organizations
to conduct their NAGPRA work.
It authorized us to assess
civil penalties against museums
who fail to comply with the
law, and it also makes it,
as Jane mentioned,
illegal to traffic
in Native-American human
remains and cultural items.
So all of those kind of buckets
of responsibility are overseen
and enforced in part by the
National NAGPRA Program,
of which I am one of
six staff members,
so we are also small and mighty.
And we've been delegated
the responsibility
of implementing these
provisions on behalf
of the Secretary
of the Interior.
So we do things like we
maintain public databases
of the inventories and
summaries that museums
and Federal agencies
were required
to put together under this law.
We publish the notices
in the Federal Register
when they make those
determinations.
We award and manage grants.
We support the Review Committee
and host public meetings.
And then we also assist in
investigating allegations
of failure to comply
with the law and then
with assessing civil penalties
when those allegations
are deemed to be valid.
So I don't want to take up too
much time, I want to leave lots
of time for questions, but
usually what I say when it comes
to NAGPRA is it's an
imperfect law because law is
by nature imperfect but
it's an important one.
And its passage was a major
milestone in the ongoing,
still today the ongoing fight
to right these historical wrongs
that were done to the indigenous
peoples of this country,
so it's one small step.
And I like to always
mention a quote actually
from former US Representative
Morris K. Udall of Arizona,
who introduced the
NAGPRA Bill back in 1990,
and he said in the larger scope
of history this is a small thing
but in the smaller scope
of conscience it may be the
biggest thing we have ever done.
So, with that.
>> Jane Sanchez: Okay.
Emily, how does your
Division and the Bureau
of Land Management
institutionally respond
to NAGPRA procedures
and requirements?
Can you tell us something about
the responsibilities, activities
and collaboration
opportunities perhaps?
>> Emily Palus: Sure.
Thank you.
So in representing the
Bureau of Land Management,
which is an agency of the US
Department of the Interior,
we are an implementor
of the Native-American Graves
Protection and Repatriation Act.
So I'll just quickly
mention that the Bureau
of Land Management manages
about 256 million acres
of public lands largely out West
in the Western United
States and Alaska.
We're a multiple use
Land Management Agency,
meaning we strive to find
balance in multiple uses
of the land, so energy,
oil and gas development,
renewable energy,
recreation, timber, grazing,
while also providing
conservation of wildlife habitat
and preservation of
archaeological sites.
It's a complex mission.
We interact with the
Native-American Graves
Protection and Repatriation Act
principally in three avenues,
which Sarah touched on.
And there is I'd say
in procedures there is
the bureaucratic process,
but I think it's important
to pause and reflect
on the humanizing part of it.
So we interact with
NAGPRA in collections,
so Native-American human
remains, objects, sacred objects
and objects of cultural
patrimony that were recovered
from agency lands, so
from public lands managed
by the Bureau of
Land Management,
or a predecessor agency,
the General Land Office.
So collections made from
those lands between 1906
with enactment of
the Antiquities Act,
which we'll talk about in a
moment, and November 16th,
1990 when NAGPRA was enacted.
Those collections represent
thousands of artifacts
and many individuals, and I've
got some figures to provide.
These collections were
largely made under permit,
under the Antiquities Act.
We also respond to
new discoveries,
which Sarah touched on,
discoveries of Native-American
human remains and cultural items
on the public lands today
and that generally falls
into two categories.
Discovery is part of land
use or development and so
if we are authorizing
development,
earth moving activity and so
on in an area that is likely
to contain Native-American
human remains
and cultural items we need
to have a plan and we develop
that plan in consultation
with potentially
affiliated Indian tribes.
We also have new discoveries
that are more haphazard
and not recreational users on
the public land, a hiker goes
out and finds some
human bone eroding out
and that can be somewhat common
depending on the landscape
and as we have an increasing
amount of recreation
in the public lands which has a
lot of benefits with the public
to use their public lands,
but with erosion and things
like that a hiker might
find remains eroding out.
We also have and actually
that's one of those things
that I'll pause and
say we're going to talk
about what NAGPRA
requires Federal agencies
and museums to do.
There's actually a provision
in NAGPRA that requires anyone,
including you, to act if
you have reason to believe
that you have found
Native-American human remains
or other cultural items on
Federal or tribal lands.
We all have a responsibility.
And so what do you do?
You contact the agency official.
The third avenue that we
interact with NAGPRA is
through law enforcement.
So I mentioned the
trafficking provision of NAGPRA,
illegal to traffic
Native-American human remains
and cultural items.
We also have another law
that links into this,
which is the Archaeological
Resources Protection Act,
which was enacted in
1979 and has provisions
that prohibit unauthorized
excavation, damage,
destruction of archaeological
sites on Federal
and Indian lands, as
well as trafficking
in such archaeological items
and in some ways
this is challenging,
but the Native-American
Graves Protection
and Repatriation Act is a
little bit of a misnomer
in that the law doesn't
wholly protect a grave.
So for new discoveries
it provides a process
by which agencies respond
if a grave is found,
the same with the
prohibited acts,
the law enforcement section of
NAGPRA is about trafficking,
not unauthorized disturbance
which is sometimes a
surprise for folks.
I've worked with
law enforcement,
I've worked on all three
of these provisions,
and we might talk about
law enforcement later,
but one example I just wanted
to share because I think
as a Federal agency
representative I can fall
into process and acronyms
and things like that
and the Native-American
Graves Protection
and Repatriation
Act is an authority
that just pulls me back
into realizing the human
impact of what I do.
And one example is a
law enforcement action
where there was a seizure
and forfeiture of artifacts,
and we went through and we were
inventorying artifacts that were
in a bucket, like the kind
you get at Home Depot,
a plastic bucket and these were
called perishable material,
items made out of plant fibers.
And there were sandals, sandals
and jeweler, seeing those
in the archaeological
record are very, you know,
these are personal adornment,
and so seeing these sandals
that had been taken from
the public lands by people
without authorization because
they thought it was fun
and interesting, but
these sandals came
down to be children's sandals.
And so I was looking at
children's sandals and this is
so real to me, these
were on some child's feet
and they were now in a bucket,
some prize for someone
who had been looting.
Our responsibilities, NAGPRA as
Sarah shared was really pivotal
in 1990 and I just want to
give a little more history
because I've mentioned
the Antiquities Act
and I've mentioned the
Archaeological Resources
Protection Act.
So 1906 Congress enacted
the law for the Preservation
of American Antiquities
and at the time it was
really this pivotal moment
where it establishes
Federal policy
that archaeological
sites were important
and should be preserved for
the benefit of all Americans,
they shouldn't be mined
as commercial resources.
And it established among other
things a permitting process
by which only those that
were deemed reputable
to do the excavations,
and so this was designed
to protect sites, but over and
my agency or the Department
of Interior issued
permits, hundreds,
thousands of investigations
of which archaeological sites,
ruins, Native-American
ancestral homes,
cemeteries were excavated.
And this is Federal policy that
this was expanding the knowledge
and so human remains
among other items ended
up on shelves and
boxes in museums.
And some were studied
and some were not.
The Archaeological Resource
Protection Act also enacted
in 1979 to address actually some
failures of the Antiquities Act,
which has a protection clause
too, but that reaffirmed some
of the permitting provisions and
again reaffirmed Federal policy
that archaeological
sites on Federal
and Indian land were important
resources to be preserved
and studied for the
benefit of all Americans,
again permitting excavation
work and the collections had
to go to a public museum.
And so the idea in 1990 that
there are groups of people
that have a higher right than
the American public at large,
and so the Native-American
Graves Protection
and Repatriation Act is a
real shift in US policy,
whereas before Interior
and other Federal agencies
would authorize the removal
in the interest of science and
education and public benefit,
this changes that and recognizes
that descendent communities
have their right
to control the disposition
of their ancestors
and cultural property
and the indigenous people
in the United States do, too.
So that's some of the history,
so I wanted to give you a
few statistics for my agency,
Bureau of Land Management.
On the collection side
we have inventory of more
than 2,100 sets of
Native-American human remains,
of those we determined 1,600
were culturally affiliated
with an Indian tribe,
and have repatriated just
about 1,200 of those
individuals.
We have also had
countless discoveries
of Native-American human
remains on the public lands
and responded in about
50 different instances
where those individuals were
then turned over to tribes.
I wanted to, you asked about
how our Division operates
and I wanted to share
a case study
which I think might
speak to that.
So I'm in the Washington Office
or Washington D.C. Office
of my Bureau and there are
offices across the West,
and largely we have an
archaeologist in each
of our state offices who
is tasked with a variety
of roles including
NAGPRA responsibilities
for collections, and I have
the honor of working with them
and supporting them on
their day-to-day tasks.
And there's a project
in particular
that really has affected
me in many ways,
it involves individuals and
collections from Alaska.
And I'll begin with I studied
archaeology and I worked
as an archaeologist in the
private sector in the Southwest,
Arizona, New Mexico, Utah.
But I learned a whole lot about
our Alaska, chasing collections
that were made by this
researcher who worked
between 1948 and 1980,
and he made 20 trips
to the Aleutian Islands.
And over my 12 years working
on this project we have found
collections in Massachusetts,
Oregon, Wisconsin, Connecticut,
Michigan, Alaska, Finland.
Some of those collections we
could find using a paper trail,
like permit records, others no.
Some of the work was done
under permits, some was not.
Most collections were made from
a singular village in a mound
that represents about
4,000 years of occupation.
And I would say we published
notice of inventory completion
in 2008 for 222 ancestral
remains, and since then we have,
and those were the ones
that were found in Wisconsin
and Connecticut and since
then we have found many more.
And we are in the process of
consolidating those collections
from multiple institutions at
the University of Alaska Museum
of the North in Fairbanks
because these collections
actually represent
or we might find some human
remains in one repository
and then looking at field notes
that we've located in archives
in another repository and marry
that up with funerary objects
that are in another repository.
And so it really is a
puzzle to pull back together
and we've found that it's
important to go through all
of that process to make
these people whole,
these graves returned whole,
and it really is a long process
and I am sometimes amazed at
where we find information.
Let's see, what else can
I tell you about this?
One aspect is I've read this
individual's dissertation
and there's a skull that's
presented in the dissertation,
which I thought I would find
in the University where he went
to University and
it wasn't there.
So now I'm thinking
maybe he took it with him
to his first teaching post
and I'm trying to work
with that institution
to gain information
about the collections
that are there.
You asked about partnerships,
and I would say that museums
and universities that hold
Federally controlled collections
can be wonderful
partners to collaborate
with through this
thoughtful process,
and sometimes they're not
and sometimes they're very
difficult to work with.
And what's a challenge for
Federal agencies or mine
and at times is that we
don't have physical custody
of the collections, we may not
have much in the way of records,
all of that could be
in the institution
or in multiple institutions
and so we end
up relying upon museums
to share information.
And yet it is our
Federal responsibility,
it is our responsibility
under NAGPRA to pursue
and complete the process
leading towards repatriation.
I'd also say the sort of
thinking about family members,
this researcher has
since passed away
but his family members
have subsequently turned
in collections that he made,
and so this is really kind
of an incredible puzzle and I
think about this was all done
in the interest of science.
And I look at how
much he published
and it really is hard sometimes
to reconcile the public,
how you all have benefitted from
these 20 trips to the Aleutians
and I'm sure at some point
hundreds and hundreds
of individuals, and
what have we learned?
And a lot of these researchers
published and a lot didn't,
and so when it comes to one
of the challenges that we had
in archaeology when NAGPRA
was first enacted was, oh,
but these individuals
have so much information,
scientific information, we need
to study them before they're
returned and are lost forever.
And when I've gone through
museums and I've seen boxes
that have been untouched
for 50 years sometimes
I frankly wonder, well,
you know, we had our chance.
I think I might leave it
there and see where you go
with questions in
my agency's role.
>> Jane Sanchez: Okay.
Thank you.
Shannon, is the Association
on American Indian
Affairs satisfied
with everything that
NAGPRA provides?
What would you like to see next?
That's kind of a
loaded question, sorry.
>> Shannon Keller O'Loughlin:
What do you all think?
Thank you.
And let me tell you a little
bit about the Association
on American Indian Affairs just
to kind of get me warmed up
and give me a chance to kind
of not be emotional
about that question.
So the Association on American
Indian Affairs is the oldest
nonprofit serving
Indian country.
We've been around since 1922.
And I don't know how much
you know about the history
of the United States
and Indian tribes,
but in 1922 that was a time
when Federal policy was
to assimilate Indians and
assimilation took many forms.
One form was boarding
schools, kidnapping children
and taking them far, far
away from their homes
and putting them
in boarding schools
where oftentimes they
suffered, they passed there,
they were buried in marked
graves, unmarked graves.
Allotment was another
policy which was a process
by which the Federal Government
sectioned off pieces of land
and gave certain acreage to
individuals who were Indian
and took away communal
ownership from that tribe,
from that particular tribe,
and that the allotment process
that went on all over the
United States took away
about nine million acres of
Indian lands at that time.
There was also ceremonies,
language, dancing,
practicing religions
and cultures,
all of these were outlawed.
In those boarding schools you
couldn't speak your language,
you couldn't practice your
religions or ceremonies.
And the Federal Government often
turned those boarding schools
over to religions,
Christian religions
to help the assimilation
process of Indian children.
And during the time
in the late 1800s
and the early 1900s it
was very popular to loot
and steal our ancestors and
objects that were in the ground,
as well as our cultural
items that were part
of everyday practices, everyday
way of life for healing,
for medicine, for identity.
And the two reasons that
Congress studied why,
what were the biggest problems
with all of this came from, one,
was the competition between
institutions and museums to see
who could get the most stuff
and so they would send
oftentimes archaeologists,
anthropologists and other people
to obtain items from tribes all
over the country and then, of
course, science and the study
of our ancestral
remains and other items
for the benefit of
the United States.
And what happened was
all of these things wound
up in institutions
all over the world,
but there was also
a segment that ended
up creating the art market,
what's known as Market
of Tribal Antiquities.
And one of the failings
of NAGPRA is
that it's very checkerboarded
in what it protects, it protects
and repatriates items that
are in Federal agencies
and within Federal hands, but
does not protect the same types
of items that are held
by private collections
all over the world.
So some of the things
that the Association
on American Indian
Affairs is doing to kind
of change the direction of this
Federal policy is changing how
the public sees our
cultural items
and our cultural patrimony,
that these items are not
for commercial purposes,
they weren't made for sale
but are just part of the history
of looting and inequality
and the lack of human
rights, of why these items are
in private collections
and upon people's walls
and decorating their
homes or for sale
at auction houses
all over the country.
We recently put out
a press release
with multiple national
organizations, both native
and non-native organizations,
tribes and firms
that do archaeological
work and universities
that basically tells the world
that these items are part
of our cultural practices,
they're sacred
and cultural patrimony,
they're not part
of the commercial market.
And instead those people
that are interested
in native cultures should be
looking towards contemporary
Native-American artists
to invest in instead
of our cultural patrimony
and our cultural history.
Now the Association was very
much involved in the passage
of NAGPRA and it started with
trying to move forward an agenda
about American Indian
religious freedom,
which wasn't very successful,
but out of that came
the NMAI Act and NAGPRA,
which at that time was an
extremely successful piece
of legislation because
it was the first time
that Congress said that
corrective measures needed
to be taken based on the failure
to enact proper human
rights legislation,
proper civil rights legislation
to protect Native-Americans
and Native-Hawaiian
organizations.
So this was the first
piece of legislation known
as human rights legislation
within the Federal
Indian Law framework.
So at the time it was extremely
successful, and I think tribes
and indigenous peoples
what we thought was going
to happen were these wonderful
relationships with institutions
and working towards the
return of these items.
And that has happened with
some Federal agencies,
some Federal agencies
and some institutions,
but today it's been almost
30 years, are we on 27 now,
28 years after the passage of
NAGPRA and there's my fellows
at NAGPRA know the
data better than I do,
but 180,000 ancestors?
Under 190,000 ancestral remains
are still within institutions
and that's what we
know from institutions
who have actually
shared that information.
There are still institutions
that are completely
out of compliance with NAGPRA.
For example, recently there
was a city library in Maine,
Massachusetts -- Medford
Public Library, Massachusetts
that was getting rid of some
items and making a little money
for its own budget and took
its Native-American collection
that was gifted to them
back in the 1880s and put it
up for auction at
Skinner Auction in Boston.
There was immediate uproar by
Native-American communities
and Medford Library and the
town of Medford quickly learned
about NAGPRA because that,
if the Skinner Auction would
have sold those items they could
have been held criminally
responsible
for violating NAGPRA.
As it stands now Medford
remains potentially libel
under civil penalties for NAGPRA
because they have not fulfilled
their NAGPRA obligations
of inventorying or providing
summaries of their collections
and consulting with tribes
so that they could proceed
with repatriation efforts.
I don't have any really nice
quote or ending piece for this,
but the work of the Association
is led by tribes, academics,
museums, lawyers working
together to try to push
and change the direction
of Federal policy
so that it's more protective of
our cultural heritage and part
of that is educating the
public about the importance
of our cultural heritage and
how it's still lacking the kind
of protection that is
seen in other countries.
I'm fortunate enough to
still be an Obama appointee,
still fulfilling my term
in the State Department
in the Cultural Property
Advisory Committee,
which is a FACA Committee,
and this Committee oversees
the 1970 UNESCO Convention
that works with other
governments
to help protect their
cultural patrimony.
And so what the CPAC
does is help to recommend
to the State Department
whether the US should enter
into a memorandum of agreement
to help protect another
country's cultural patrimony
from being imported into the US.
So if we see certain types
of cultural patrimony
from another country we let
it be known and give it back.
But those same types of
protections aren't available
for Native-American cultural
patrimony and heritage,
and we are still working
on legislation called the
Safeguarding Tribal Objects
of Patrimony Act, it's
currently in Congress
and it's maybe not going to
be passed in this Congress
but we're hoping next
Congress it will.
And what it does is it helps
remedy that one-sided mechanism
where the US is only protecting
other countries' cultural
patrimony, instead
it allows the US
to develop bilateral
agreements with other countries
who are market countries
for Native-American items,
such as Germany, France
and other parts of Europe,
so that they will
protect our items
if they see them being
imported into their countries.
The Stop Act also has an
importation, I'm sorry,
an exportation requirement
so when Homeland Security
or TSA sees certain types
of items that are going
to be shipped over to other
countries there would be a
process in place to help protect
Native-American cultural items.
So there is movement to
expand current protections
for Native-American
cultural heritage,
but we still have a long way to
go and part of that has to do
with changing perceptions
of the antiquities market
and antiquities dealer who makes
a lot of money from these items.
I was once involved in stopping
the sale of some wampum belts,
which many northeastern tribes
have used throughout their
history and are no
different than our Declaration
of Independence, it's that type
of national cultural patrimony.
And some of these
wampum belts have gone
for Native-American100,000
or more, and so being able
to stop the sale of that
as you can imagine
would be quite difficult
because of the financial
interest
that that collector has
in a particular item.
So but that's what AAIA
is doing is trying to work
with the public,
work with collectors,
work with auction houses to
try to find options of how
to return those types of
patrimony since NAGPRA
and other law may not apply.
So, with that, I'll end.
Thank you.
>> Jane Sanchez: Okay.
I have a couple more
prepared questions,
but I thought I'd go ahead
and open it up to all of you
to ask questions
yourselves, so anyone?
Oh, come on?
Back in the corner?
>> Hi, I actually
have two questions.
You said that you had found
some remains all the way back
in Finland, and I'm wondering
if it's harder sometimes
to get those from
other countries
because you have international
laws that you have to go
through as well and
they might not
since they're further removed
from the history they might,
I don't know if they can
grasp its importance as much?
And the my other
question is this is not
like really something that's
like new, like we have mummies
in display in museums that were
taken from the graves in Egypt
and other cultures who
have artifacts taken
from their burial sites
throughout the world,
is there something
that you guys do
because this is a very
self-selected group
to outreach the public to sort
of make that culture change
so that we can start
viewing these things
as like this is a
human, this is a body,
as opposed to like putting
it on display to study?
>> Emily Palus: I'll start
with the international.
Thank you for picking
up on that.
So the Finland trade is
something that I'm working on,
but I'll start with there's a
collection, another collection
from Alaska not associated with
the researcher I talked about,
another researcher that the
collection we discovered
in Switzerland.
And the University or
professor took a call
from someone's child, adult
child, who said I'm cleaning
out my father's house, would
you be interested in coming over
and you can have any of
the archaeological stuff?
So he went over and, lo and
behold, 120 boxes of artifacts
that were actually recovered as
part of a permitted excavation,
actually I've gotten
a copy of the permit,
and were to be curated
in Fairbanks,
Alaska but were shipped
to Switzerland as part
of this researcher was going
to do analysis and
then return them.
That must have slipped through
the cracks because that was
in the late 60s, early 1970s.
So that collection we
learned this last year
when the professor who took
the fateful call, he went
and he salvaged the
material from this residence
and he has it in his lab and
is working with his students
to repackage it because it
was in no condition to ship,
and it has been a very, it's
been a wonderful collaboration.
This is my first international
foray so I'm grateful
to have a good partner, and
we've met with State Department,
Homeland Security, US
Fish and Wildlife Service,
and so I'm working through
those with a collaborative.
We haven't fully
broached Finland yet,
the Finnish institution because
we're trying to get copies
of the loan documentation
from the museum that did.
I keep calling it a loan,
it's not a loan that they did.
So but we get this one project
under our belts then
we'll go for the others.
Now it can be complicated
because we are talking
about international lines, and
in some instances it's US policy
to send examples of our artwork
and historical items overseas
to spread information
about American culture.
But for us what we will tie
back to is our domestic laws,
that these were collected
from public lands,
they remain Federal property
that cannot be conveyed except
under current law, repatriated
to culturally affiliated
Indian tribes, so.
>> Jane Sanchez: I think
the other question?
>> Shannon Keller O'Loughlin:
Well, I wanted to approach,
I wanted to respond to the
international question, too.
Because one of the
difficulties that we have trying
to get collections back from
international institutions is
that those countries have their
own laws that often declares
that those things that they hold
are their national patrimony.
So, for example, Spain
was a conquering country
of indigenous people and peoples
and took a lot of items back
to Spain, and there are items
in Spain that are now part
of their cultural patrimony,
even though they were looted
and stolen and taken from
the indigenous peoples here.
So it becomes a different kind
of discussion that you have
with an international
government and you have to go
through their laws as well.
And one thing that is
often not addressed,
even though these items
have a Federal tie,
they came from Federal lands,
they are part of what's kind
of considered Federal
property even though I don't
like to consider our
ancestral remains
and cultural items in that way.
And so they're inalienable
from the Federal Government,
but Native-Americans'
items which are inalienable
to us it is very difficult
for us to argue to collectors
and others that there are items
that are inalienable to us
and to our nations, that no one
has the authority to give away,
and the only reason why they're
in other people's hands is
through theft and
looting or some kind
of illegitimate taking.
So it's great that we have that
Federal tie-in with many items,
but there are still many
more where we don't have
that Federal tie-in and we don't
have any strong Federal law
that will support the argument
that these are our
unalienable items
that could not have been
taken except through theft.
But I totally missed
your second question.
>> I was just asking like
if you guys do education
or outreach programs to
sort of shift or create
that culture shift to where
people see these items
for what they are, like
funerary items or human remains,
and humanize them as opposed
to just looking at
them behind glass?
>> Sarah Glass: Yes, I mean we,
a big part of what the National
NAGPRA Program does is offer
training, resources, technical
assistance to museums,
but obviously since we're the
NAGPRA Program we are focused
on NAGPRA items, domestic
issues, but that doesn't mean
that we don't still try to
get involved in this kind
of broader culture shift
and this broader
application of this work.
So, for example, my
boss, Melanie O'Brian,
who is the Manager of the
National NAGPRA Program,
actually traveled with
an interagency delegation
to France earlier this year, to
Paris to try to educate and meet
with government officials
there, our officials to talk
about why are these
Paris auctions
of sacred Native-American items
such a big deal, why do we care?
Because there's just not
that recognition, right,
or even language,
even the translations.
When you say a sacred object and
that has a very specific meaning
under US law and to
different tribes over here,
when you say sacred in French
that doesn't necessarily
equate in the same way.
So, yes, we do try to do our
best to educate to the extent
under the law, for me at least
being restricted by that.
When I do get calls about
people asking about mummies
or other kind of grave goods,
I remember being shocked
when I went through to Italy
and went through museums
and just saw body after body
after body from Vesuvius
and was kind of taken
aback by that,
but it's just a more normal
practice still I would say
in some parts of the world.
But here luckily with that
kind of shift in these fields,
in archaeology, I was an
archaeologist undergrad
and anthropologist and
museum studies, you know,
that's the new guard
I think moving
in to start shifting our
perceptions of that and not just
because NAGPRA says you have to,
but because this is what's
the right thing to do as well.
So I think that's the direction
that most people, not everyone,
but most people are
tending towards.
Maybe I'm optimistic.
>> Emily Palus: If I could,
I want to touch on this, too,
because I think a lot of
it comes down to consent,
consent of the descendent
community
and what is a cultural norm.
And so what's so pivotal about
NAGPRA is that it describes
that while the Federal
Government actually had this
policy of excavating and
study and display was
in the public interest
and then reversed
that because recognizing
that Indian people,
Native-American people have the
right to control the disposition
of their ancestors and not
the 500 and plus tribes
in Native-Alaskan communities,
not everyone has the
exact same world view.
And there are some tribes
that will take remains
and rebury them on their
lands, there are some tribes
that will take remains
and rebury them as close
to the original interment as
possible, there are some tribes
that allow study,
there are some tribes
that allow intrusive
study, it's their consent
and I think what it
comes down to is consent.
But I agree that sometimes it's
sort of shocking when you walk
into a museum and see
human remains everywhere.
I was doing a behind-the-scenes
tour, a repository review
of an institution that
held Federal collections,
and we walked into the
physical anthropology labs,
physical anthropology
human remains.
And the curator opened
up these wardrobe doors
and there was just shelves
of skulls, and I fell back
because I, well, one, I didn't
know that was coming and even
if I'm not a Native-American I
think a little heads-up would
have been, excuse me, a little
warning that that would have,
yes, that this was happening.
And then there was a gasp,
one of my colleagues gasped.
And she said, oh, no, no,
it's okay, they're from Peru,
they're not subject to
NAGPRA so it's okay.
And then also actually
the same institution,
and now the story I'm telling
is about from 15 years ago,
they've changed course
dramatically,
but there was a display of --
you push the button so it's
interactive, you push the button
and this woman on the
phone says, hello, hello,
I found something in my garage.
And the story is that this
woman went into her garage
and there was a box and she
opened up the box and, well,
there was mummified, naturally
mummified human remains.
And the story was that her
husband or his friends had gone
over to Mexico and
brought them back.
I'm not sure how they ended up
at this museum, but the story
and how it was presented was
this kind of, oh, my gosh,
this woman walked into her
garage and found this box
with mummified remains in it.
And, no, that kind of display,
that actually was sensational,
but that's just not appropriate.
And I think that that
story is changing.
I guess the last thing I
would say is I'm grateful
for this opportunity to come
here and talk to this group
about this statute with
my esteemed colleagues.
>> Shannon Keller
O'Loughlin: Thanks.
And to talk a little bit
about public education
and what opportunities there
are for you all, the Association
on American Indian Affairs
is a membership nonprofit
organization and
anyone can be a member
if you pay Native-American35,
which is actually very
powerful for the work we do.
We do a lot of national
public education and advocacy,
as well as grassroots
work on the ground
with tribes implementing
programs on the ground.
So having membership that's
representative of all of us
in the United States I think
really tells a strong story
about some of the
issues and the programs
and the education we're trying
to do, that we're backed
by a diverse community
of individuals,
not just indigenous
Americans but everyone.
So I encourage you to
participate in some
of the programs the
Association has.
We just got done with a
Repatriation Conference
where there were
tribal practitioners,
spiritual leaders, museum
curators, foreign institutions,
lawyers and a variety of
people working together
to find ways towards more
success in repatriation efforts,
not just with NAGPRA but also
those things that fall outside
of NAGPRA or in foreign
institutions.
So there are opportunities
to be educated
and I think there's a lot
in the media right now,
so if you search auctions,
Native-American cultural items,
if you look on the Association's
website you're going
to find a lot of
information available for you.
>> Sarah Glass: Yes, it is
becoming more well known
for sure, these issues
are getting attention now
like never before, so
that's a positive thing.
>> Jane Sanchez: The sad
thing to me is that it wasn't
until 1990, wow,
yikes, that's terrible.
Anyone else?
Oh, come on?
>> So you said that the NAGPRA
Program is an imperfect law,
are there other countries
that are doing it right
or have it a little bit closer,
that you kind of hold as, oh,
this is how they're doing it,
like maybe we can take things
from them, or are we like doing
the best we can and we're kind
of at the end, you
know, beginning of it?
>> Sarah Glass: That's a good
question, it's a great question.
Yes, it just, so it's
been almost 30 years
since NAGPRA was passed and
I think it's safe to say
that no one that was drafting
NAGPRA 30 years ago really
thought that this work was
still going to be going on now
in the way that it has.
And, as we've mentioned, the
statistics are still kind
of mindboggling about just
how much is still left to do.
And there's gaps, as
we've pointed out.
So there are other countries
that have laws in place
to address these
similar types of issues.
Australia being one of
them, New Zealand, Canada.
So other countries that
have these kind of histories
of indigenous populations,
imperialistic people moving in,
power imbalances that are
inherent in then the power,
the country that takes power.
I don't -- maybe
someone else can speak
to if they're doing any better
than what NAGPRA is doing,
but I know that often
this is used as an example
of how you can at least try
to shift that power imbalance
and try to start doing that
work of righting past wrongs.
I know another international
kind of outreach thing
that the National NAGPRA Program
did, we actually sent staff
to Japan because they have a
very strong centralized program
for acknowledging and
putting out a list
of their national treasures,
things that they consider
national cultural treasures
from dance to art, to
all sorts of things.
And so that was a kind
of cross-cultural
learning experience about,
oh, how do you do it?
And it really just comes down
to every country is different,
every situation is different.
The United States has
such strong protections
of personal property and that
property law that can get
so gray sometimes
or so hard to fight
when it's private property,
and I don't ever see the
United States saying, yes,
we're going to take
your private property
because it's the
right thing to do.
But, sorry, I rambled there.
>> Shannon Keller O'Loughlin:
Well, I'm looking for a day
that we will have
some kind of mechanism
to allow the taking
of stolen property.
And, as I said earlier, most
of the cultural patrimony
and sacred patrimony
and funerary items
and human remains were
taken illegitimately
because they could be
considered inalienable
from those nations,
from those tribes.
NAGPRA really is I hate
to say the gold standard,
but it is really the best
out there for a process
by which indigenous peoples can
have the items repatriated back
to them.
Other countries are much better
at protecting their
national heritage than we are
and don't checkerboard
the protections
up like the United
States does because of
that private property
type of mentality
that we have here in the US.
So in other countries
you see mechanisms
by which all land is
protected so no one can go in
and start digging and all of
a sudden declare ownership
of that human burial
or of those items
that they found in the ground.
And it's not like that here and
what's even more interesting is
that we do have Federal law
in the United States
that's highly prohibitive
of the same type of private
property issue when it comes
to endangered species
and collecting
or selling endangered species,
such as the Golden Eagle
and Bald Eagle Protection Act.
So if I'm standing at my house
and a Bald Eagle dies and falls
in front of me I have absolutely
no rights to that animal
or parts of that animal, I have
to call someone to take it.
But if I find something in my
land, if I find amazing pottery
or even human remains
depending on what state I live
in there may be no other laws
that protect the affiliated
tribe's rights to those things
and I can start my own museum
in my garage with what I find
in my own, on my own
private property.
So there's a little bit
of disparate thinking,
unconnected thinking when
we're looking at protection
of Native-American cultural
heritage and it really goes back
into how our Federal laws
apply to indigenous peoples,
which is based on this kind of
schizophrenic notion that tribes
and Indian peoples are sovereign
but at the same time
they're inferior.
And so depending on the whims
of the current Administration
oftentimes our Federal policies
protecting Native-Americans and
Native-American heritage kind
of wings one way or the other
because our Federal laws are
so schizophrenic when protecting
indigenous peoples here.
>> Hi, I really don't have a
question, but I just wanted
to kind of piggyback a comment
in response to that question.
So I'm the Interim Director
of the National Association
of Tribal Historic
Preservation Officers.
Prior to, I was the Tribal
Historic Preservation Officer
for my tribe in Lac du
Flambeau, Wisconsin.
I started under a NAGPRA
grant, not knowing anything
about NAGPRA, never even knew
that my ancestor remains were
in museums and other
institutions,
so it's been an incredible
education
that I've had since
the year 2000.
What I have seen in that
time thanks to NAGPRA a lot
of ancestors are returning home,
a lot of their belongings
are returning home,
and that's been phenomenal.
What I've also seen in my own
community is we are beefing
up our travel codes
and ordinances
to protect our ancestral
remains and resting places,
but also the states,
I'm starting
to see more states take that on.
Wisconsin just passed a revised
Burial Sites Preservation Law
that protects burials,
categorized, or catalogued
or uncatalogued, and it actually
empowered our inter-tribal
repatriation community
in Wisconsin
when ancestral remains are
discovered during certain
projects, excavations,
whether it's on private land
or public land it is left
up to the inter-tribal
repatriation committee
to determine disposition
of those human remains,
where they're going to
be repatriated, buried,
what happens with them.
So on top of what we have
Federally we're starting
to see tribes and states take
a more proactive approach
in beefing up their
laws to prohibit
and protect ancestral
burial remains.
>> Jane Sanchez: Okay.
I think it's time to
begin our closing.
I'd like to thank
everyone involved
in making this Panel possible.
Shannon, Emily and
Sarah, thank you so much
for joining us this evening.
Thank you, all, for
spending your evening with us
and celebrating the
70th Anniversary
of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights.
We've come a long way since the
adoption of the Declaration,
but we must also acknowledge
that we have not lived
up to its full vision.
So as we celebrate
tonight we must also commit
to working harder to make the
Declaration's ideal a reality
in people's lives.
We must support the work
of human rights defenders,
nongovernmental organizations,
experts, policymakers,
journalists and all peoples of
conscience, and we must continue
until the timeless and
universal principles
in the Declaration become
not just an inspiration
or an aspiration but the
foundation of life for all
of the world's people.
Thank you, once again, and
have a great evening, everyone.
Thank you.
[applause]